welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid first I want to say that I know
we've been doing a lot of Einstein's
relativity lately it's challenging stuff
I also know that some of you were a
little confused about space-time
diagrams and I kind of glazed over the
details in the comment responses we're
going to address some of those details
in this video and then starting next
month we're gonna get back to some
normal topics I must bring balance to
the force I mean to the channel okay
let's start with some basics first
spacetime is a giant collection of
points called events those events can be
anything the moment a car begins to move
the moment it stops that time you woke
up in bed this morning your birth the
Big Bang or you clicking this video a
spacetime interval is what you get when
you connect to events all the events
between the front and the back of the
car we call its link all the events
between when this car starts and when it
stops
we call it space-time path how slanted
that path is depends on speed anything
with mass me the car a water molecule
the earth or proton anything you might
call an object must travel more through
time than it does through space the time
component is always bigger for the
space-time path of an object things
without mass like photons of light
trouble long diagonal paths where the
time and space components are the same
size weight the same size yeah that's
where things get weird we use something
called a line element to measure the
size of a spacetime path and in flat
space-time it looks something like this
you can see it's not traditionally flat
because of the stupid negative time
behaves opposite to space for objects
like you or me this isn't such a big
deal we move more through time so our
paths have size light on the other hand
light always moves the same through time
and space which means it's time in space
perfectly cancel each other and since we
base all other measurements on space and
time all measurements in a massless
particles frame are 0 photons
experienced all time in a single moment
in all space in a single place no no we
see it move around at the speed of light
so it must experience both you're not
thinking four dimensionally remember all
motion is relative so is
face its the universe in which we live
so you better keep up the pace we see
light move with great ferocity even when
it gleams but the closer you get to its
velocity the smaller space of time seems
ok that's enough of that thanks for
liking sharing and subscribing and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy oh I almost forgot
more comments Keizer cube mentioned that
the speed of light might have been given
the symbol C for the Latin word salir
toss meaning swiftness there's actually
some historical debate about this it is
true that the letter C for Solera toss
was used extensively in wave equations
during the 1800's to represent the speed
of a way however the C used for the
speed of light did not come from a wave
equation it came from a disproven
alternative to Maxwell's
electromagnetism where it represented a
constant history is kind of a blundered
mess I also mentioned that the curvature
equations in relativity were only
defined locally and whoever I am I am
was wondering how locally exactly
technically speaking in contessa mele
local they really only apply over
infinitely small intervals in space-time
which is true of most fundamental
physics equations
it's the changes from one event to the
next are really small though you can get
away with applying the word local to
whole objects are collections of objects
but at that point you're just
approximating okay that's it for real
next time there's a normal topic